okay I had no idea how much I look like
Taos Manson until everyone now sells me
[Music]
you have two huge rolls coming up
playing the same character yes
tell us minutes and squid that's right
what was that like like were you filming
them in tandem with each other were they
far enough apart that you could kind of
differentiate no they were only two
weeks apart but but I finished mine
hunter first and then once upon a time
in Hollywood have a start at two weeks
after that so but there are there's an
11-year age gap in the in the mountains
so there's a there's a slight variation
both in how they look and also you know
how it at the same time is that like
that's that's so funny it's like a weird
complement of being like yes thank you
do I look like Charles Mann no I know it
listen III did not know that
okay had no idea how I might feel look
like tells Manson until everyone now
tells me so I don't know quite how to
take it but it led to these jobs so I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna go with it now
there's so much buzz about once upon a
time Holly what can you tell me about
your experience working on that fun yeah
is the most fun I've ever had I think on
a job it was just you know I'm not
allowed to really say anything about
what the scenes were that I shot but
everybody was so lovely Gwen Tarantino
is just a nice guy just full of
enthusiasm every second of the day and
you know they played 60s pop music
between shots and it's just like you're
just pinching yourself the whole time
Wow so they really gets you into this is
where you are in time yeah and he's just
got you know he's got the privilege of
having so much time to make a movie that
it never feels rushed it never feels
like anybody's you know pushing you to
be faster it's just a very relaxed
environment and yeah I had a ball